and chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of
our New York station WCBS is here with
the timeline of the moments leading up
to and after totality Lonnie good
morning well good morning to you as well
let's break it down for you because it's
all going to begin about 90 minutes
prior to the total eclipse that's when
the moon is gonna start to cross the
face of the Sun this is the partial
eclipse and everybody in the country is
going to see this in some semblance now
as the moon covers 90% of the sky that
sky is gonna dim a little bit
temperatures will drop a little bit as
well but it's two minutes before the
total eclipse that 99% of the Sun is
going to be blocked so you're gonna get
the colors of like a really nice-looking
sunset and although you only see this
little sliver of the Sun you still have
got to be wearing your protective lenses
because this little sliver is still
about ten thousand times brighter than a
full moon but again it's looking pretty
cool out there you keep the glasses on
as you make your way closer and closer
to tatts to totality if you're in the
path you were going to see just before
the moon covers the Sun something called
Baily's beads and these are the last
spots of light just peeking through the
moon's craters the very last spot
creates this diamond ring effect and
then it's totality it will last two
minutes 38 seconds the stars are gonna
be visible overhead you will be able to
see the corona of the Sun my goodness I
wish I could see something like this
here in New York we get about 71 percent
coverage it's going to be totally cool
to see and this is the only time that
you can take a look at the sky at this
image with your naked eye but if you're
not in the path this time perhaps you're
gonna be luckier in 2024 that's the
country's next total solar eclipse that
one goes from Texas to Maine so for
those of us here in New York City we may
have a better shot at it then nor let's
go over to you
Aulani that is such a good explanation
thank you so much you bet
I love the excitement of everybody who
wants to go I do Lonnie I was at the
Martha's Vineyard Airport yesterday I
met people who come from London who were
heading from Martha's Vineyard to st.
Joe Missouri because they wanted to see
it they feel it's a once-in-a-lifetime
thing for them a lot of people this is
this is good they describe it as a
spiritual experience in other ways I'll
be on West 57th Street let's see what
happens there right that's Anthony Mason
however we'll anchor at two hours ApS
news special report on the Eclipse so if
you're not outside you don't watch
beginning
one Easter noon Central right here on
CBS